how food taste is not just determined by
the ingredients used to make it at a
research kitchen in London a psychology
professor and a top chef are trying to
see how big of a role perception plays
Mark Phillips did some taste testing to
see how sound and smell can change the
flavor the promotional video for this
combined London restaurant and food lab
sounds like a game show and it is call
it the spoon game try to get to the
chef's mind and arrange the spoons in
the way that you imagine he might have
thought your four spoons for colored
flavor balls and oxford university
psychology professor charles spence
makes you pick which color you think
will provide which taste
there's no right answers but no right
answers but you'd be surprised at the
number of people who give the same
answer that's what honestly I'm saying
salty bitter sweet sweet okay the proof
is in the tasting later sour they taste
like when you expect green tangy things
to taste like and this should be the
sweet one right it went on a sweetener
hmm right it turns out three-quarters of
people associate the same colors with
the same tastes and line the spoons up
in the same way so why is that useful it
is if you're trying to get people to eat
less sugar if you're thinking about our
food and beverage companies who may be
wanting to reduce the sugar and some of
their drinks just say make it red and if
you've passed the spoon test with yes
flying colors
try the jelly bean test with a nose
clamp this is not a piece of but let's
go ahead do now is give you a jelly bean
and taste it and think about what do you
get on the Swedish side the game here is
to taste the bean with the nose clamp on
and suddenly you get the and then off
lemony this
try nasal smell whenever you swallow to
the pulse of volatile rich air comes out
that's where most of the taste really
resides what the taste bugs buds on my
tongue we're telling me him was what you
called taste when I took the clip off
and got the hole who had the thing
that's flavour what people colloquially
call taste and that matters for example
with airplane food the dry cabin air and
low pressure means surprise surprise
that you don't get the full flavor which
is why twenty to thirty percent more
salt and sugar can be added to produce
the same taste as on the ground
appreciating the effect environment can
have on taste and even experimenting
with bringing that environment to the
table is why airlines and food producers
pay for the kind of research done here
what if for example you're trying to get
people to eat more sustainable food in
this case something which has been
swarming our coastlines but which you
probably would never have thought of
putting on your plate so what you have
here is a plate with jellyfish a dish
enhanced by adding a seaside soundtrack
so headphones jellyfish
chef Joseph Youssef does a mean
marinated jellyfish cue the music it may
not be at the top of everyone's list but
dress it up with a table top projection
of ocean waves and add ocean sounds
through the headphones and
all this helps with kind of getting them
into that place where they're excited
about trying something new excited about
trying something different okay this
would be good enough without the music
but I see your point the point is that
as we move forward in what we eat
presentation counts perhaps like never
before for CBS this morning i'm mark
phillips in london i don't wanna eat
every meal now with headphones on and
waves crashing music in the world could
make it worse eating jellyfish oh it's
good you tried it yeah well I get it I
get it
now it's all connected but it makes
sense that when you have a cold you
can't really taste it it's also nice
smell is exactly exactly an airplane
food as well